it's not easy it's hard changing your
life it was hard when just over three
years ago in the Penobscot building in
Detroit Michigan where I was operating
my business and I fell on some hard
times and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and he said would
you mind reading it here and I open the
envelope and the envelope was from
management that says this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I say excuse me
sir I said I just worked long hours and
creating my business I'm an entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be this way always
and I just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate like I'm doing I'm
not trying to make this my home and it
was hard coming through the lobby and
sometimes they would laugh there's a guy
talking about becoming successful and
look at it he's bathing in the bathroom
upstairs on the 21st floor he sleeps on
the floor him and two other dreamers up
there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentleman
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself
and say God why why is this happening to
me I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did it have
to happen to me
it was very hard and here's what I want
to say to you for those of you that have
experienced some hardships don't give up
on your dream no one could have
convinced me by holding on by continuing
to push forward by continuing to run
toward my dream at one day I would have
my own talk show it's a longshot ladies
and gentlemen from Liberty City an
abandoned building on a floor never
knowing my mother or father it's a long
shot
being here with you today in the dome in
Atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ] but i kept ready to walk my
dream
no spell
don't doubt
don't stop running toward your dream
[Applause]
[Music]
it's very important as you hold on to
that dream the moments when you're going
to doubt yourself they're rough times
are gonna come but they have not come to
stay they have come to pass it's very
important you to know that
don't say I'm having a bad day say I'm
having a character-building day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's very important for you to believe
that you are the one to make this happen
I remember this high school teacher mr.
Leroy Washington at the end of school
one June with just a few days before we
were supposed to leave and I just got my
report card and it indicated that I'd
failed history and I fail English and I
would have to go to summer school and I
was feeling within myself that I was a
failure that I'm slower than most people
and getting paperwork and and I was
feeling down on myself and and and very
negative and mr. Washington was giving a
speech to the graduating seniors and I
was in the 11th grade and even though I
wasn't supposed to be in there I went in
there because the speech he was giving
that speech was for me and as he talked
my heart began to beat fast tears begin
to run behind my eyes and I was in the
back just listening to him because he
said and he was a very dramatic man I
still talk to him to this day he said as
graduating seniors of Booker T
Washington High School I want you to
know that you're blessed and highly
favored and that as you go toward the
future begin to know that you have
greatness within you and if just one of
you here begin to envision yourselves as
being blessed and highly favored to
reach your goal if just one of you
capture the essence of what that means
that you have greatness within you and
responsibility to manifest that
greatness
that you can make your parents proud you
can make your school proud you can touch
millions of people's lives and the world
will never be the same again because you
came this way and the students gave him
a rousing standing ovation and as he
left the auditorium I ran down the steps
and I caught him in a parking lot I said
mr. Washington he said yes I said do you
remember me sir he said no I said uh my
name is Leslie Brown my mother she works
in the cafeteria here I wanted twins
Leslie Wesley specifics Washington but
you know you know I got these big dreams
and I like talking to people I love
people I said I want to work with people
and I got this Bheema by my mom our home
cook could I do that mr. Washington
he said it's possible Miss Brown and as
he walked away I called him again I said
mr. Washington he said what do you want
now I said on
I'm the one sir I said I'm the one you
you remember me sir
I'm this maybe browse for I'm the word
I'm the world
[Music]
you